[Music]
in tech-savvy beggars news what the hell
submitted by sack Oh potatoes Chinese
beggars are now accepting mobile
payments what Chinese beggars are now
accepting mobile payment oh no do they
have like a phone with like a square
swiping no PayPal
they have like a little sticker with the
the via what is that the QR code that's
the one genius are you [ __ ] serious
to have QR codes on the homeless people
amazing holy [ __ ] [ __ ] he's
like send me Bitcoin these beggars are
now having QR codes while they're asking
for money Wow
why do you come one beggar he's a human
being so you can no longer say sorry I
don't have any cash on me what [ __ ] I
see you on your phone
damn you have no legs because I saw a
video where they tie their things
together and then they pretend that they
don't have legs it was here oh yeah I
saw it with you guys scroll through all
the videos and find that probably about
300 videos ago that'll be really easy to
find that's why I'm always fine to talk
[ __ ] about like whatever is going on in
my life and my parents and [ __ ] because
they'll never ever forget it so mom I
think you're a dyke okay who does find
all that stuff though shout outs to
James Rodolfo yeah because your video
the [ __ ] that we do it and he'll put it
up and I love them pretty much once you
scan this QR code you can pull up your
alley pay or your WeChat wallet or some
other mobile payment app that we have in
China and they can make donations that
way there are also companies are hiring
some of these beggars to have people
just scan the code and for every single
code that they are getting sponsorships
yes every code that they get scanned
they'll get about 10 to 22 cents and so
they're saying that they average about
six hundred eighty five dollars a month
that's really cool yeah so then they're
just they want to get a job all do you
want you to do just scan it like you
don't the donate just scan this code and
they get money I'm not
the company is like pushing there it's
kind of like flyers you know like the
players that people pass out he's a
happy looking yeah I'll show you guys a
clipper here I'm not mad at it they
found a loophole man oh man people are
my weakness I can't here we go same same
[Music]
you know I posit she was saying like I
can't scan her called my cell phones out
of batteries I can't scan it and it's
didn't that's when she busted out the
credit card machine sorry I don't have
mobile payment setup and they pull out
like like a like a credit card old
credit card yeah the one from home alone
- yeah I just where that's the only
movie I ever saw it in like like VP was
alone - they always charge the dad's car
I think that's just a that paper that
transfer paper right and then they print
it out yeah yeah an old elementary
school papers and [ __ ] yeah what was it
last year that got finally like phased
out fog maybe like in the 90s 1990 I've
never even seen interrupted Jeana I want
to see it I'm sorry I really do okay
here we go
no need for me yeah change change change
watch what she was like off [ __ ] give me
give me this off I'll give this up
okay what's scanning for them like
that's okay like it doesn't bother me if
I don't have to give money you know and
it's just getting and they get like a
little bit Commission so I don't know
why I'm skin yeah oh you know what there
are some reports saying that they're
getting their weekend profiles would
have had all their personal information
and then they get like unsolicited
in-app advertisements for these
comforters no such thing as a free lunch
yeah I got it I got it have a backup
phone with my crazy Chinese billionaire
money just for that so when they send
the money then they get info or whenever
they scan the code well when you scan it
yeah like these these companies are
small businesses apparently to they're
just collecting people's data cameras
genius it's really smart yeah cuz
they're making Bank on that [ __ ] like
what do you think Gmail is like a huge
enterprise because they just go with
mine through your whole thing and then
they target ads at you that's why they
know how did you know I just looked at
that [ __ ] fishing pool Amazon how was
it how was it popping up on my Instagram
you know there's an option to turn that
off and it won't be tailored to you but
then when I did that they'll push like
some weird-ass products to me I'm like
oh go back to tailor a beard cold [ __ ]
and now red it's doing it to where
they're like going through all of the
sub reddits that you're like subscribe
to so they can gauge your interest
I mean Instagram does that right now and
they sell your info yeah Instagram does
all those all you guys are doing it my
facebook time likes I'm like how'd you
know I know all right I would I would be
a sucker for this around your personal
time because old people I'm such a
sucker for people what if that old
person used to be a brothel owner and
whipped the hookers and stuff well what
if this old person was a pedophile
expert I don't know I mean he's a
pedophile expert
that's not that bad he's an expert being
a pedophile yeah he's an expert at being
petal fish oh I wouldn't know that
that's I mean that's why he's like a
black belt at pedophilia yeah he's a
grandmaster of pedophiles yeah it's
pretty in child quando oh my god that's
creative man I got to give it to Chinese
people on that one that's creative as
[ __ ] where did I go to get this though
soup kitchen they're everywhere now I
was in Bali and I turn on the news and
may have a QR code in the lower right so
you just scan it so you can stand for
more information download an app or
whatever's I thought they were worth
seeing back in like [ __ ] 2000 we
didn't adopt your codes here yeah and I
thought they died off but then they're
like Reese like resurfacing it you know
yeah they even updated like the newest
iPhone stuff they updated so the camera
roll can and QR codes you don't need a
whole separate app for that anymore
yeah mobile payments are getting to be
huge in Southeast Asia like your PayPal
like you can give them your QR code
that's that's what I was gonna ask
because I didn't know how key our QR
codes are skating like that you need an
app for it well now like I use whatsapp
on my computer I do is turn on the
what's up and I take my phone and I just
take a picture of it now it's linked
whatever is on my phone is on my
computer what did they integrate that
which iPhone they might even have it at
for really oh [ __ ] your camera roll know
that this is a new thing because I just
recently discovered that well not on the
camera revenue up the yeah it's always
wondered how you scan QR codes before
you have to download an app I see but
this shit's giving all these people
economic power where they didn't have it
before because basically in a lot of
these countries you cannot get access to
banking because it's only for rich
people who are because they charge crazy
fees and like they want to keep it to
put to a certain clientele but I like
using your phone as a payments system
like almost like a mobile bank he's
allowing people to it'll be in different
ways don't trust banks either drew
because I know a lot of my friends
parents they just kept cash in their
house and stuff they didn't really like
them trust the banks because back end of
Vietnam or whatever you know so you're
saying that they trust these things more
than I think no I mean without people
going into the banks and in signing up
and doing all those things they probably
trust like their cell phone more
especially if you don't have
access like let's say you live in the
village or let's say you live somewhere
so far away from the main city it takes
you miles and miles and you don't have
transportation yeah I wonder how they
get paid out I do they go to the company
headquarters and they accumulate how
many scans you add or something you want
to have to get people withdraw like once
a month or something oh they probably
get it on their own
or maybe they don't even need it to pay
out because maybe every scan it's
automatically in their phone and now if
they want to go buy water they just go
to use their phone ago yeah they never
even have to have a cash transaction
ever yeah that's what I was gonna
mention that the interesting thing about
what they mentioned in this article is
that China is probably the closest
country in the world that's that's
getting to a cashless economy oh [ __ ]
coming a cohhd cohhd economy that's cool
it economy or something that yeah so
like they don't need cash anymore it's
just everything is on your phone wow
that's scary you know Japan's trying to
be cashless by 2020 when the Olympics is
there so when the Olympics people come
over then they can they don't have to
like sit there and transfer all the
money and all that stuff I like that
because goddamn they have so many coins
I know
[ __ ] point person just for being in
Japan to Ben Davis coin purse it had to
be kind of olive green and and Gaia Sh
yeah cuz I'm gonna have that [ __ ] old
lady's nutsack a little hell no I got
mine a zipper to get the Ben Davis like
gorilla on it it's and the zippers rough
to just Superman in case you cut your
finger I need to show you man like [ __ ]
it's crazy to think that even our kids
will one day and not even know cash yeah
like it's it's the next generation do
you think it's gonna ever be like a
thing where cash is obsolete is that the
pan paper really yeah it's just so much
more convenient especially because then
you don't have to carry cash any but
what if the system's down I mean now
there's all these other different
systems but what if you want to buy
drugs what system cuz now blockchain is
coming in dude
so and you can't take blockchain down
with blockchain it's like Bitcoin II
things stuff so but think of it like the
internet right like like there's a many
different servers so if you were to blow
up a building you can't take out the
internet yeah
the blockchain is like it's like it's
it's all like there's nodes all over the
world and so you can't target it in one
place and take the system now right it
has like ten G's in or whatever that
information stored in like 12 different
places so one thing goes down it's over
sir it's an infinite ledger that has
every financial and like piece of
information on what if I ran out of
battery on my phone and I need to buy
something then you're very the bottle of
cell phone from a homeless person well
maybe it'll get to the point where
another is you know now even Apple has
wireless charging there's like wild
wireless chargers everywhere I'm pretty
damn I'm print charging if you think we
got cancer now wait till we get wireless
charging charging thumbprint pain you
can pay for things with your thumb great
well now you need to pay with your face
I would like that too but then I would
make my chin face-to-face has to be my
code I would time I buy something
[Music]